unemployment hit a record-high 14.7%
with more than 20 million jobs lost in
april it's a hit the country expected of
course and on Fox and Friends yesterday
President Trump says he's optimistic we
will bounce back quickly
we had the strongest economy in the
history of the world the strongest
economy we've ever had and we had it
closed it which is artificial we
artificially closed it those jobs will
all be back and they'll be back very
soon and next year we're gonna have a
phenomenal you so what are the next
steps to jumpstart the economy we have
the best person to answer that question
right now joining us now the chair of
the president's revitalization Council
HUD secretary dr. ben Carson mr.
secretary thank you very much for being
on the program you've got to be
absolutely friend of the show if you
have a big job on your hands you had a
meeting yesterday about it what is top
of mind for you as you tackle this task
of revitalizing our economic engine well
first of all I think it's very important
to point out that you know this economic
crisis that we're experiencing right now
I was intentional and it was on the back
of an extraordinarily strong economy yes
and 2008 it was just the opposite we had
a very weak economy so this is a
different situation altogether and it's
very important that we not allow that
economic infrastructure to be destroyed
so that we can rapidly get back on that
train again so what we want to do is
make sure that we preserve particularly
the small businesses the small
businesses are the backbone of the
economy of this country they employ the
vast majority of Americans and the the
longer you know we stay shuttered the
more of those small businesses will die
still on that forefront of what we're
thinking about is how do we make sure
that we preserve the viability of those
small businesses and a lot of that has
to do with using our brains
intelligently not allowing this virus to
completely dominate
but in fact how do we control it and
live with it
until we have the ability to completely
eliminate it if we wait until it's all
gone
before we come out all right absolutely
right
doctor the president has laid out
guidelines and then basically said hey
states it's on governors to manage their
reopening but we see a protest across
the country a lot of governor's taking
it really slow a lot of big states where
cities have cut cases but counties have
none how can you incentivize governors
to actually allow people to responsibly
reopen who are ready to do so their
livelihoods are at stake they don't want
to bail out they don't want another PPP
loan they want to open their doors
because they know they can targets wide
open my small retailer isn't what more
can be done to actually make sure that
happens I think what we have to do is
emphasize data and evidence you know we
have enough places that are opening
under various circumstances that we can
look at what has happened there
particularly when people are wise enough
to follow the guidelines you know make
sure that you keep your hands wash be
careful about what you touch wear the
mask where appropriate remain continue
to maintain the social distancing when
we do those things it is eminently
possible to go back to work you know
except for the people who are very
vulnerable the elderly people people who
have significant underlying problems
that could interfere with their immune
response obviously those people we need
to protect and we need to make sure that
the people around them understand the
principle but when that's the case
there's absolutely no reason that we
can't go back in governor's like anybody
else ought to be able to understand data
when it's presented absolutely that is
that is common sense that is trust in
the American people that's letting
people make their own risk calculations
doctor I I wish you all the best you
have a huge job which with massive
consequences for our country you've got
the medical background as well as the
economic side we have an enormous team
virtually all the agencies and
United States government are involved
everyone's contributing tremendously to
this and this is America and we're gonna
get it done
amen keep those keep the heat on those
governors a lot of them have slow
rolling alright dr. ben Carson
appreciate your time thank you so much